I didn't realize that when fresh outfit
put out that live stream and said they
were gonna nuke our Channel they just
ended up nuking their own I don't know
why Myron did this but he decided to go
on scenico's live stream on Rumble
you have to wear that too yeah of course
how am I gonna break this down if I'm
not in my proper attire as a race bro
all right can you move over a little bit
okay I'm moving over [__] you see out
of that you [__] sandic but it's okay
white supremacist Sanic shut up you're
[__] bro you're the worst the worst you
eat dogs and you kill people as a black
guy
in Asia
yeah that's true
this [__] right here is funny it's
funny I don't condone this N word oh
shut up your Albanian
keep running the clip you drink
no keep running the clips who's that
weirdness that can't speak
who's that he black as hell
all right
just crying right now swinging from a
monkey Branch eating a banana plant some
Donkey Kong gonna add 64 because he's a
stupid prick he's a window licking
stupid what what
hey
spin
I like that this video
running like it's an employment line
what the [__] what don't do that I will
find you you [__] stinky looking
piece of [__] you go [__] fat right
here I don't like you already I don't
know how you guys did it
but you guys made a more embarrassing
response than h3h3
buy like a long mile never ever share
that Myron do to them [__] Jews you
[__]
is this a character this this is this is
not representative this way you change
keep going no I don't think they do so
you damn right there high value man they
say more lives than your monkey asses
have what the [__] you doing y'all
sitting there in that tight ass real
I'll see you next little [__] monkey
we dreads for a decade
same shitty [__] camera for a damn
decade same shitty Road Mike right there
it looks like a penis forever you guys
have not proved nothing and you [__]
millionaires now that's back in the
business get called out my [__] K
member out of Tennessee you
[__] are losers I'm roasting
y'all right now continue on channel yes
okay
that [__] sound like he got a 39 IQ
holy [__] I don't know how this guy
preachers take it seriously like this is
[__] stupid say Albanian freeze I
said about shut the [__] up you [__]
you stupid not showing the women that
y'all are with not one time last time I
checked out my Renee got like three or
four girlfriends okay and they're
friends with each other they would hurt
our fan base but if you're securing who
you are no your favorite low IQ feminist
that can't take it when you get fit what
does he do he actually gets fresh and
most importantly fit that Fresh Prince
for helping everybody get a goddamn
shake this art is totally unhinged what
do you mean what do you mean you told me
the N word watch you are okay yeah we do
like 10 cents uh cross burnings and and
here's the thing I'm going to continue
to roast them they're going to sit there
and say okay let's [__] go ten toes
down I will roast you [__]
until the end you [__] homos got
nothing else yeah I think I caught a
little that was a little hardcore this
little hardcore even for me I'm glad you
didn't show up in a white Hood Nick that
would uh
Optics you know I was gonna do the Maga
hat but it just it wouldn't go as hard
as the white Hood so Nick your folders
are going to Myron now you got
competition
that's for both of you guys both of you
guys are it's like I'm being outdone I
thought I went pretty hard in November
leading the dissident right now yeah
it's a couple of the Albanian and a
black guy
how things have changed because I
remember when Dave Chappelle did the
Clayton Bisbee Bixby [__] back in the
day it was [__] hilarious but
nowadays you do that [__] they're like
oh my God just goes to Charlotte
pusified we've become if you're looking
at that Donkey Kong photo I can conclude
that he's also a monkey okay
the [__] Arab guy that's also black
that literally like I hit so many
different check marks for the KKK y'all
want to call me cool you [__] if
you're wondering who the white dude in
the top left is that's a white Supreme
Nick Fuentes who's the leader of a
far-right movement and uh just pearly
thinks
I will say just probably thinks orange
does look good on you I'm glad you took
Britney's advice I do think it's funny
that the only time you decide to groom
yourself is for a clan meeting but hey
if that's the kind of high value man you
want to attract go girlfriend
I can't do it yeah
what the [__] I heard that some of y'all
were raising the salute so I decided to
come back let's go before sneak though
for all rolls out oh come on no we're
done dad's gone no no let's go we're
down for whatever
let's do it
do you realize how dumb everyone has to
be that when you're in a room full of
people that somehow just pearly things
seems to be the smartest person you see
her sliding off screen like what the
[__] am I associating myself with
y'all know how dumb you have to be to
make pearls sound smart yeah I mean Hey
listen if you want to throw away your
YouTube channel in the dumbest way
possible cool you just cost yourself and
your staff millions of dollars over one
of the dumbest things I've ever seen
possible and also just notice
all of this rolls off Myra's tongue so
easily this is not the first time he's
talked about this about black people
like this it's not surprising to me I'm
honestly when he started speaking about
black women in the past I'd always
suspected he has negative emotions or
feelings about black people about the
black dating app called Black
it's funny I never used that one bro but
hey man
I mean hey bro if you want to date a
bunch of shaniquas go for it man
Laquisha yeah like me and fresh aren't
really down with the brown like that we
ain't Night Riders so I'm good uh you
know sometimes if they're you know
Redbone but like in general me and fresh
uh don't dabble in the dark if you know
what I'm saying yep um okay and this
just reinforced it it's just like
I'm not even upset I'm just like oh yeah
at first it starts with making you know
talking [__] about black women
specifically and constantly putting them
down and you know sometimes there's
valid criticisms about Black Culture
that I'll entertain but then the
frequency and the victory that comes out
when they speak about it you start to
feel like there's something else going
on underneath it all and then when it
comes to people like mine even though
you can never point to it directly
because it's rare that it's this overt
so you can't really point it out right
everyone tells you no it's not there's
not there even though you have a feeling
you know what I'm saying you have no but
now you have it in full in front of you
this guy is considered the leader of the
red pill and you're seeing how this
disseminates to a lot of his followers
that kind of hatred that he has for
black people is instilled in a lot of
the things that he actually preaches you
can't tell because it's not overt but
it's in the undertones if you understand
what's really going on that's why when I
saw the previous one even though a lot
of people said no it's not it's not
racist it's not it's not it's like do
you really think that I know it is I
know what he means when he says the
warrior Gene I know what he means when
he says monkey I know why he's using it
specifically for a black individual but
plausible deniability gives everyone the
ability to be like no that's not what he
meant that's not what he meant but with
this stream you just see everything that
I believed and pretty much knew is
confirmed
um so yeah I mean if you want to shoot
your credibility if you want to distort
your movement if you want to make the
red pill look like a movement for losers
that hate women and also hate minorities
and value whiteness for some reason you
know it's in your dating preferences
it's in your language it's in the way
that you insult people that's okay have
your movement but when people discredit
it and laugh at it you're going to be
one of the principal reasons why with
your behavior instead of holding frame
instead of being stoic the way you
present in the red pill and handling
your stuff well you get poked in prod
and all of a sudden you unleash this the
reason why this came out is because deep
down inside that's that [__] that you
feel that's the stuff that you really
believe that's how you really feel about
black people
and now everyone else knows um so you
know if you're proud of this
congratulations brother you played
yourself I don't think there's much to
be said I wouldn't be surprised if the
YouTube channel gets deleted as far as
them talking about hanging us or monkeys
this or whatever it is cool